autoridades de una treintena de países
incluidos ministros de exteriores de
china y rúsia aceptar la limitación de
francia italia y alemania- para
acompañar a libia en su difícil
transición hacia la democracia después
de diez años de caos político desatado
tras la muerte de muamar gadafi la
primera buena señal para estos países
fue la presencia en parís de las dos
principales autoridades de la transición
en libia que representa justamente a los
dos bandos enfrentados en ese país el
este y el oeste me refiero al presidente
del consejo de la presidencia y al
primer ministro tras esta cumbre las
autoridades acordaron primero mantener
el calendario electoral de transición en
libia y realizar el próximo 24 de
diciembre elecciones legislativas y
presidenciales de manera simultánea de
elecciones inclusivas los países se
comprometieron también a sancionar a
quienes no acepten los resultados y a
enviar observadores electorales la
segunda medida o decisión fue más bien
felicitar al grupo 5 más 5 formado por
militares de ambos bandos este y oeste
que han logrado mantener primero el cese
al fuego desde octubre del año pasado en
libia y que se disponen los próximos
expulsar a 300 mercenarios extranjeros
de ese país que es otra de las causas
del caos libio de hecho según naciones
unidas hay 20 mil escenarios extranjeros
en el país principalmente rusos del chat
de sudán e incluso sirios y finalmente
el grupo de autoridades se comprometió a
apoyar a libia para combatir el tráfico
de seres humanos que ha hecho que este
país sea la ruta más peligrosa y más
masiva de la migración de áfrica hacia
europa